[Music]
[Applause]
i
want to welcome everyone to this
evening's colloquium i'm scott osterwa
i'm the creative director of the mit
education arcade
and i've been coordinating this false
colloquia
um just my usual announcement which is
uh if you are someone um from the mit
community you're probably
automatically promoted to a panelist uh
which
means at the end of the talk you're free
to sort of ask questions out loud
verbally
if you are if you're an attendee um
you're also welcome to ask questions
uh through the q a channel on zoom
um so if if i happen to recognize
if somebody i may promote you to
panelists but otherwise
you can use the qa the qa function um
just to raise questions
um and with that i'm going to turn over
i'm going to turn over the event to
professor
heather hendershot who's going to
introduce our speaker and so
heather take it away hello and uh hi
in particular to those of you who i've
not yet met it's nice to see you in
little tiny squares on my screen
crushing your head
um i'm really uh delighted
that we've got adam hart here uh
speaking to us today
um he is the author of
this book monstrous forms moving image
horror across media which is a fantastic
book um he is currently working on two
other books
one on george a romero and also a
historical and theoretical study of
handheld cinematography
and film television and video um
and i mean as far as the romero book
goes it's hard to imagine anyone
alive in america today or in the world
who is better positioned
to write a book on romero from the
archival standpoint at least
so i'm really excited about that and i'm
also really excited about the other book
on handheld cinematography um it engages
with the avant-garde with cinema verite
with newsreels tv documentaries just a
whole range of texts
uh there's one um essay that's
from this forthcoming book um that's
already been published in discourse that
i encourage you
to check it out in that uh in that
journal
um and uh just in general i really
appreciate adam's work for its
theoretical and historical
rigor but also you know for the clarity
and the precision of his prose it is
really um a delight
to read his work um adam is taught at
harvard
at north carolina state university at
the university of pittsburgh
he's currently a visiting researcher at
libraries where his work centers on the
george a
romero collection which he will tell you
about right now
so on to adam hello everyone
thanks so much heather thanks scott um
so uh i'll just say to start off
um that i've done a few versions of this
talk um and some are a bit more
sort of a slideshow of all the cool
stuff
from the george a romero archive this
one is a little bit more focused
but there's some digressions into a
bunch of just like hey
look at all this cool stuff i found um
but i can certainly indulge
in much more of that in the q a or if
you wanted to
follow up um you know by email
or whatever at a at a later time i'm
always thrilled to talk about this stuff
um okay so i'm gonna try to share my
screen
all right
okay um all right
so this talk is an early attempt for me
to process the gigantic
mass of material that i've been sifting
through from pitt library's george
a romero collection which they acquired
last year
um so uh again
this is a bit more focused but that's
not to say there isn't digressions
um the story that i'm going to tell in
analyzing
a later film of romero's viewers from
beatnik theater
to 2001 a space odyssey fan fiction
to bigfoot to the pittsburgh steelers to
a florida community college and a few
other points in between
and it's an evolving story in very
literal ways i spent the last few months
sifting through
hundreds of scripts and boxes of
materials
but i've also been speaking with
romero's collaborators
and trying to track down leads about
other projects
one of the amazing things about this
archive is that
even though we have literally hundreds
of uh hundreds of projects
we have about 300 scripts for
unproduced films um
coming to about uh a hundred 120
distinct individual projects but
everyone that we've spoken to
mentions some other additional project
that they worked on with
george romero so we're finding more and
more
and one of those leads suddenly started
to pay off
in the last couple of weeks so one of
the projects that i'll be speaking about
today um briefly is a short film that's
basically unknown never been screened
publicly
called jacaranda joe that romero filmed
in the 1990s but again it's never been
publicly screened
and suddenly in the last couple of weeks
i've been able to get in touch
with people who worked on it and people
who may have additional
materials so while i've been
you know digging through the archive
here
i guess i'm also working to build the
archive in all sorts of ways
um and so you know we'll we'll see where
all of this lands uh
in the next few months um but anyways
uh i have been calling this talk and its
focus on
cameras and filmmaking in romero's movie
romero's movies uh what the hell's with
that camera anyway
so night of the living dead debuted more
than 50 years ago
in pittsburgh on october 2nd 1968 and
nobody involved really knew what to
expect
a plucky band of 20-somethings led by
co-writer director and cinematographer
george
a romero had made what they called
pittsburgh's first
feature film shooting largely in a
farmhouse just
outside the city this ultra indie low
budget
exploitation movie would somehow
grow in stature over the next decade or
so
gaining a shocking amount of
respectability for a black and white
movie from pittsburgh
about flesh-eating corpses but the team
that had worked around the clock for
more than a year
saw almost no direct profit
from a movie that truly changed horror
and in a lot of ways
also changed independent cinema
distributor
incompetence put the film in the public
domain which meant that
anybody with a print could show it for
free
well distributor greed kept the
filmmakers from seeing all but a
fraction
of the box office it was a success in
cinemas but because it was in the public
domain
it became a staple of late night
programming for any tv executive looking
to fill time for free
and so throughout the 1970s and into the
80s
it went some pre-internet version of
viral
and scarred several generations of
children channel flipping late at night
in the process
so the team managed to get several more
features under their belt
in the next few years trying to expand
their palette beyond the black and white
gut cruncher that made them famous
but all those movies were woefully
unsuccessful
playing only a handful of theaters and
not receiving any widespread
distribution
so the team disbanded more or less
romero
stuck around in pittsburgh continued
writing scripts
and continued working to build a local
industry making commercials
tv industrials but he would really only
get the chance to return to features by
returning to the horror genre
and by returning to his very first film
with a sequel dawn of the dead
but even then it took the clout of high
profile fan
dario argento and his european dollars
to get it financed that sequel dawn of
the dead would be
a substantial hit but he stayed in
pittsburgh as
independently as he could over the years
his brief dabblings with the margins of
studio productions were wretched
experiences and in 1999 after about a
decade of frustration
and uh inability to get a feature into
production
he moved his filmmaking a few hours
north to toronto
where a friendlier tax code and
government support
made intimate independent productions
easier to undertake
so romero never sought to become a
horror specialist
and he certainly never intended to
corner
the market on flesh-eating zombies
but it let him work and he found ways to
bring themes tones and styles from his
other projects
into the films he was able to make and
for a filmmaker as fiercely independent
and as far removed geographically from
hollywood as he was
he had a productive career directing 16
features
several of which had become beloved even
outside of the genre's die hards
so he and his friends invented a new
monster the
undead zombie that had taken hold in the
global imagination
in a way that maybe no other 20th
century monster had
when was the last time a filmmaker
invented a myth as pervasive
and recognizable as the romero zombie
the stumbling corpse driven only to feed
on the living every horror fan knows and
loves freddie and jason and michael and
even frankenstein's monster in bella
lugosi's dracula
but how many jason movies were made in
south korea
in the 2010s are any art house legends
like jim jarmisch making nightmare on
elm street movies
how many mile michael myers musicals
have there been
and i just recently learned of the
existence of disney channel
zombie teen musicals um which
i suppose i have to figure out a way to
watch now just um
you know out of pure curiosity's sake
to find other kinds of films with this
sort of global
footprint you'd probably have to go to
gigantic blockbusters like
jaws and star wars
but that kind of pervasive cultural
influence comes at a price
we know romero as the man who gave us
zombies and who made a bunch of zombie
movies
and that's how distributors and
financiers knew him as well
his few attempts to stray from zombie
and zombie adjacent movies did not leave
much of a dent at the box office and if
some have been recuperated as cult
classics over the years
they didn't necessarily help him get his
next movie financed
after night he was the zombie guy to
studios
to funders to audiences to critics to
fans
he never exactly resented that he once
likened it to
a golden prison in which the food is
the best food you've ever eaten
but it was limiting in a way that did
not reflect his full artistic ambitions
he stumbled backwards into horror after
failing to get funding for previous
features
most heartbreakingly for him wine of the
fawn which we have
production materials and a script for um
it's an artsy coming-of-age story tinted
with allegory
that's set in the middle ages and
clearly influenced by ingmar bergman
and orson welles so in 2019
when the university of pittsburgh
libraries acquired romero's archives
we started to see a very different story
that could be told about george romero
as an artist uh the archive shows a
remarkably prolific
writer whose interest so i guess this is
the actual archive here
whose interest went beyond horror and
way beyond zombies western slapstick
kids movies sci-fi
epics cartoons talky dramas and on and
on and on
in all we have more than 300 drafts for
about 120 different projects
but romero never got the chance to film
or publish
during his lifetime there are mentions
of at least a dozen more that we have
come across in contracts
in correspondence or in conversation
with former collaborators
nearly everyone we've spoken to has
mentioned at least one other project
that romero worked on uh including works
with multiple drafts that got far enough
into production to begin raising money
as a writer he was astonishingly
prolific
um it's clear that some of the shorter
treatments were written because writing
them was fun
um so um
uh here we have an x-rated frankenstein
spoof called peterstein
um that was written in the 1970s from
the 90s
um a bonkers little tv treatment called
nuns from outer space
um about aliens that happen to resemble
nuns
and their language happens to remember
biblical speak
the utterly delightful monster mash this
is my absolute favorite thing
in the archive um monster mesh
is a comedy about a team of mutants
monsters creatures and the like who
travel
around the world to administer emergency
medical treatment to wounded and ailing
monsters like themselves
the title would be stylized with
mash all capitalized
it's hilarious and delightful and even
though it's only 12 pages long romero
manages to work
in a rousing indictment of the
capitalist health care system
in his brief proposal um and
if filming it would have required an
effects budget
roughly equal to the full budget of his
previous several features combined
it ends with a jokey decoration the
project's financial promise
think of the fun no forget the fun think
of the toys
the tv series the animated version on
sunday saturday morning think of the
bucks
written in the mid 90s when all of
romero's projects seemed to be
cursed and film after film turned to ash
the irony of this conclusion was thick
and bitter and
premised on the assumption the very idea
of a george romero movie with a
blockbuster budget was utterly absurd
but that didn't mean he couldn't have
fun writing it
um so other stuff that we have in
the archive we have photos
just amazing behind the scenes photos
that have never been seen before
and script pages from knight of the
living dead
that tell us a whole lot about the
actual production
this is my all-time favorite bit of
marginalia
from the shooting script of night of the
living dead george realized that he
needed corpse shots
for a particular sequence um
here we have an early version of martin
which is my favorite of
romero's movies which is not at all
about a teenage vampire it's about
the vague ennui of a middle-aged
businessman
and through this early fragment into the
early drafts we can trace its
evolution to um into what it is
on the screen um he made
uh he wrote a bunch of scripts for
sci-fi
epics in the 1980s including war of the
worlds
um a collaboration with a fellow yinzer
and marvel comics legend jim shooter
um a sort of set in the future space
superhero story
um and uh you know maybe
my second favorite thing in the archive
which is materials for
a stage adaptation of a space rock
sci-fi musical tales of hoffman
so that he wanted to stage at carnegie
mellon university
um okay but we're going to focus here on
diary of the dead and tracing back some
ideas
from that so in my book
and elsewhere um i've discussed the
so-called found footage
horror movie typified by blair witch
project and paranormal activity
and there i aligned the diegetic camera
the camera that's recording within the
world of the film
with a kind of vulnerability it's a look
that's associated not with the power and
control
of what apparatus theory has dubbed the
gaze
but rather with weakness danger and
exposure it's always
partial and fragmentary and always
reminds the viewer of all the unseen
space just out of frame and all the
unseen threats that may be lurking there
it's exceedingly rare for a camera
operator to survive
a found footage film which might not
seem unusual for a horror film
taken in isolation but the format all
but guarantees
the death of the protagonist more
reliably than any other
subgenre so you can see what i mean here
can you guys hear all right okay
mary
[__] that's a very young time
guys
guys what's happening [__] god damn it
[Music]
hello
you found this in one of the other rooms
tell us your name uh say it
deb come on say it give me a break jay
jason
jason creed you see how it feels to have
a camera shoved in your face
okay so romero in one of what would be
the first wave of found footage movies
there's a weird sort of lacuna where
blair which project comes out in 1999
and then in 2007 to 2008 a bunch of
found footage movies including
cloverfield
uh wreck from spain diary of the dead
and the
first theatrical festival version of
paranormal activity
all came out one after another um
and so unique among those romero is
thematizing the
problems and sort of moral failings of
filming but he's also aware of the sort
of fragmentary partial nature of
of the camera and calling our attention
to everything that we can't see
um okay so
um shoot lost my place all right
so in diary which follows
a group of university of pittsburgh film
students and their professor
as the zombie apocalypse breaks out
during the filming
of a cheesy student horror movie
the director of that student film jason
creed
decides to document the chaos with his
video camera
romero's movie consists of sounded
images recorded by creed and his friends
including his girlfriend deborah who we
just saw who is i suppose the film's
nominal protagonist
they are not just camera operators but
also editors
compiling their footage and uploading it
to the internet as they go
unlike many of that first wave of found
footage horror movies were watching a
completed film
rather than raw footage so uniquely
the film openly pathologizes jason's
need to film
and keep filming with other film with
other characters seeing it not just as a
distraction
but an intrusion a way of avoiding
engagement with a trauma befalling the
world
that includes the sometimes urgent
danger that flesh-eating zombies
inflict on his friends he insists on
experiencing
the world through the lens of his video
camera and then uploading the next part
of his movie to social media
each time he finds a connection again
the film pathologizes its compulsion
likening it to the zombie virus itself a
few surviving characters
ending the film shooting each other in
security
monitors after locking themselves away
from the world in a panic room of a
friend's mansion
the lens of the camera makes them unable
to interact with anyone on a human level
it makes them in essence less human
feeding off the pain
and suffering of others and it seems to
be trans
transmissible to anyone who picks up a
camera it came easily to you didn't it
says the film professor
maxwell here calling jason's film a
diary of cruelty
um this is them shutting themselves off
at the end of the film
um and though debra her professor and
one other student survived the zombies
by locking themselves away from the
world
they've been infected by the camera
virus debra finishes the movie and
uploads it online
in her voiceover she makes it clear that
she's finishing it for
jason an act of disavowal that rhymes
with jason
blaming his infection on his professor
earlier in the film
and which has implications for the
film's understanding of the camera in
the camera virus
she's been overtaken by jason's illness
and has resigned herself to her fate
there's no sense in her work of drive or
urgency
no enthusiasm in her voice jason she
says thought he might be able to make a
difference
maybe change the world she has taken up
its mission but she's merely going
through the motions
no affect no drive of her own she's
alive but isolated
uh active her activities having been
reduced to the blank consumption and
production of images
the completion of someone else's work
work which she seems to actively
detest as if she lacks a will of her own
she is essentially a zombie
as with most found footage movies the
camera operator jason dies and in the
typical way of
found footage his now zombified friend
still in costume from the mummy film
sneaks up behind him off camera luckily
for the purposes of deborah's edit
he manages to turn around just in time
to catch a glimpse
before the attack so this is what i mean
when i discuss the inherent
vulnerability
of found footage's diegetic camera
source of anxiety and found footage
horror comes from the urgent knowledge
of the disparity between the camera's
viewpoint
and the possible locations of threats
but it tends to be used as an attempt to
assert control
capturing the threat in your camera
stabilizes it and seems to provide the
kind of distance or even security
that jason presumes for himself but
those around jason
they clearly understand him to be hiding
behind the camera
as an act of both cowardice and even
cruelty
filming and perhaps making zombie movies
in particular
because jason is making a zombie movie
um being fundamentally inhumane
so the film ends
with a coda that doesn't appear in most
drafts of the screenplay
play it it's a little less than a minute
for those of you who've seen knight of
the living dead once said he thought he
could help
should look familiar maybe even save
some lives
this is the last thing he downloaded
before he died
a couple of hometown joes who went out
to shoot at targets
but that day they used people dead
people
you know just for fun
there was one target that was different
from the rest
a woman tied by her hair to the branch
of a tree
the boys had this one set up just for
kicks
they got out their favorite 12 gauge and
are we worth saving you tell me
um if anybody here is squeamish i
apologize that is
the only bit of gore that i'm sending
your way in this talk
i think um okay so
um for those of you who have seen out of
living dead this is deeply familiar
in that film ben and i'm gonna play this
uh on mute while i talk
ben the african-american hero it's a
lone human of the main characters to
survive the night
and after surviving an onslaught of the
undead
he is as we see here he's killed by a
posse of local hunters and police
all white uh um varying german shepherds
who must take him for a zombie and shoot
him right between the eyes
all right vince hit him in the head
right between the eyes
[Music]
good shot okay he's dead let's go get
him that's another one for the fire
apologies to anybody who hasn't seen it
for spoiling the ending of a 52 year old
film
still we're seeing them um so in night
the tragedy the gutting emotional
devastations of the ending
comes not just from the death of the
charismatic hero but from the
realization that this white
posse fails to recognize his humanity
in the original script uh they realized
their mistake
adding a note of bland non-committal
regret
um it's too bad an accident the only
loss we had the whole night
in the finished film instead as soon as
he dies the film immediately cuts to
still images of ben's body
being dragged with meat hooks and lifted
onto a pyre
so diary has none of that narrative
motivation to its
zombie hunting coda it's simple dumb
cruel spectacle of bloody target
practice with the targets being people
dead people but debra identifies one
zombie different from the rest
a woman tied to a tree branch by her
hair
the clear sadism misogyny and lack of
empathy
for zombies or humans or anything the
sheer lack of recognition
is chilling and the film fades to black
with deborah morosey
questioning whether humanity even
deserves to be saved
the monstrosity of filmmaking and of
filmmaking as a pursuit
clearly reaches a pinnacle in romero's
work here as it's hard to go any farther
where this sadistic spectacle for the
camera
becomes an indictment of the whole of
humanity with cameras
in 2007 getting smaller and cheaper
and starting to migrate onto our phones
and computers
we were all becoming filmmakers and we
were all becoming consumers of images
what dams us as a society is not that
this video was filmed
by a couple of quote hometown joes but
that people watch it
that it's downloaded over and over again
this is perhaps an unexpected conclusion
from a horror filmmaker whose movies in
the 60s 70s and 80s
were gory enough to scandalize more
conservative viewers
and earn a few bands around the world
the suspicion of filmmaking however was
something that he had been working
through
for a very long time excuse me
so this is where i'm going to indulge in
a few archival digressions
but it all comes back together i promise
in an
envelope in an envelope marked old
writings in the archive
there were a number of short stories
fragments and treatments that romero
wrote in the 60s and early 70s
including two versions of a story one of
which is
titled enemies neither is dated but i
feel safe
asserting that the one on the left the
untitled shorter story came
first as it is a barely elaborated
barely altered version of the first
segment of 2001 a space odyssey
in which two tribes of pre-human apes
fight over territory
and then on the right in what i'm
presuming to be the second version
which retains some of the same
descriptions of characters
and a basic framework romero digs deeper
into the psyches
of the proto-human characters and into
the functioning of their society
so romero's films and screenplays his
zombie films in particular
tend to be more immediately concerned
with the monstrosity
of humans vibrating violent and cruel
racist misogynist
classist exploitative and he thinks of
monsters as a kind of radical
alternative to
humanity and crucially to human
civilization
and structures of society if zombies are
fairly blank
ideological vehicles say for their
function of overturning everything and
feasting on the remains
there is still a progression throughout
his career as he becomes increasingly
concerned
with excavating traces of humanity
amongst the growling feeding
undead and if zombie society doesn't
necessarily
necessarily model a kind of utopian
community
some of his creature scripts do
the zombies uh always suggest an end
to a society um to a cruel society
expressing more than anything else an
urgent desire to start
over but the creatures tend to provide a
different model
we can follow so uh around this time or
possibly a couple years later
romero was on his own in debt and unable
to raise money for future productions
he was writing a ton but getting nothing
made besides commercials in the
occasional commission
that is until he met a video maker and
technician named richard rubinstein
who interviewed him for a small industry
publication called the filmmakers
newsletter in 1973.
in those days video also meant
television and
after hitting it off the two of them
started cooking up ideas for
collaboration
that could help restore romero's
fortunes in the world of production
working in pittsburgh and utterly
unwilling to leave romero was far from
the centers of production
financing he had a tarnished track
record and a negative balance in the
bank
but he did have something a kind of
unique
kind of local resource that was utterly
unique to this to the city
the pittsburgh steelers who along with
the pirates and a handful of other
athletes
were leading a remarkable sports
renaissance in a city that was otherwise
rapidly declining in both
economic and cultural standing like
other mid-sized cities with long-time
sports franchises
the steelers were incorporated into the
dna
of the place an essential cultural
institution
and at no time was that more true than
the 1970s
and at no time were they more popular
outside of the city
either so in 1973
romero made a 50-some minute documentary
about the steelers most popular player
running back franco harris that served
as a sort of proof of concept
for the next sports documentary o.j
simpson
juice on the loose which was broadcast
on national network
television uh in 1974.
um if you've heard of it it's because it
received a minor revival in the 90s as
some of romero's collaborators
try to capitalize on exploit
simpson's newfound infamy um
a brief aside romero was always a vocal
fan of kubrick in the mix of slapstick
and blacker than black satire of a film
like dr strangelove can be seen
in most of romero's films of the 1970s
but weirdly the oj documentary was
also a tribute to kubrick the original
concept for the film
was to give it a title acknowledging
simpson's newly broken rushing record
that rift on kubrick
2003 yards a football odyssey
titles i have to say were never a
strength for romero
but that initial inspiration remains in
the opening of the film
which is a highlight montage set to
zarathustra
so based on the moderate but important
success
of the simpson documentary romero and
rubenstein used the
the franco dock which they had finished
as the pilot for a new tv series called
the winners
that they'd spent the next year that
they'd spend the next year and a half
producing it had no network home so it
was more like a group of specials
produced under
the banner of the winners than a
conventional television show
it consisted of profiles of prominent
sports figures
largely but not exclusively pittsburgh
figures
like pirates hall of famer wooley
stargel professional wrestling pioneer
runo san martino and nascar legend
mario andretti and most importantly
three more documentaries on various
steelers players
romero directed a handful the franco
dock and the bruno san martino dock are
particularly wonderful
as they double as idiosyncratic
portraits of the city
and its fans but it provided
romero and a growing family of crew and
collaborators with regular work
laying the groundwork for a film
industry in the steel city
and making it possible for romero to
continue working in pittsburgh with
local talent
but it would be several years before you
would get to make another feature
so during the production of the winners
romero and rubenstein were still trying
to get features made
and of course the most logical
possibility was a sequel to romero's
massively successful debut
in early 1974 he met with american
international pictures
founded by roger corman along with james
nicholson and sam
arkoff although only arkov were made at
that time about producing a sequel
called
dawn of the dead the initial idea for
dawn was always
was already there a small group of
survivors secluded from the chaos and
the zombie apocalypse
in a shopping mall um though it would be
several years before the familiar
narrative structure and cast of
characters
from the finish film would fall into
place
no film came from that meeting but the
feedback was crucial for romero's
efforts over the next few years
aip was interest and interested in
producing it
but they were at the time looking to
market their films to quote
niche audiences so they wanted romero to
rewrite it for an all-black cast and
they wanted to
put a superstar athlete in the lead
now there was really only one athlete
popular enough to star
in a movie at that time and romero had
just made a documentary with him
o.j simpson but romero quickly found out
that oj wasn't available
or wasn't interested he was already
starring in a studio super production
the towering inferno which would have
been both occupying simpson's time
and probably pushing him out of reach
for aip's budgetary possibilities
so this aip collaboration fizzled out
but the idea of using a high profile
athlete to get a feature
made clearly stuck with romero he had
grown very close to both the players and
the executives of the steelers
and if franco harris wasn't famous
enough to open a movie made
even on the margins of hollywood he
might be enough of a draw for the
purposes of romero's
ultra indie low budget productions so he
came up with two projects for franco
working with a steelers organization of
various degrees on both of them
the first is a truly bizarre spoof of
50s creature features and teen movies
called monster movie in which franco and
whichever steelers they could get to
show up
would play horny college athletes trying
to survive an alien invasion
it obviously never went anywhere
but romero obtained an official
partnership with the steelers
for a second a movie called footage
which is yet another
atrocious title devised by romero upon
referring to the creature bigfoot
uh it's built around a film crew that's
uh
that's recording images footage um and
possibly a triple pun
also on nfl football um
it's a sort of proto-found footage film
built around a film crew in the images
they've recorded but
never actually screening the footage
within the structure of the film
so there are several versions of the
stories with sometimes big variations
and it's unclear as they're not dated
which versions come earlier or later
the basic stories about a tv show called
outdoorsman usa
or some slight variation on that in
which franco would have starred as the
guest host
on the tv show a famous nfl quarterback
and one
version a country music superstar as
well
the show's crew and hunting experts
would lead him through the woods in
search of game
or at least that was the show's premise
in the film
they encounter a baby bigfoot and
someone carries a crying child back to
their camp
the baby was not alone but part of a
society of big feet
living deep in the woods and they rush
after the kidnappers
the humans in all versions respond
immediately
with gunfire in one minute in one
version
a crew member sees that the big feet are
intelligent enough to understand what
guns are
so he holds his barrel against the
adorable baby bigfoot's head
um as with knight of the living dead the
bulk of the film is devoted to arguments
within the group of humans
and demonstrating their own inherent
monstrosity
which is contrasted directly with the
family concern and love of the bigfoot
society
he's also clearly working out some of
his frustrations with the industry
as the slimy anti-semitic producer
tries to force the camera operator to
give him
the film of the big feet uh
with a camera operator resisting because
he knows that that would ensure
the destruction of this natural
community
in the woods uh one version of the film
one version of the film ends with a
camera
camera operator in the athlete winning
the moral arguments returning the baby
bigfoot
and discarding the film uh ending with
the big feet celebrating
they don't understand what film is of
course and the script ends with them
throwing the reels in the air like
streamers
in some versions uh romero returns to
the
hostage-taking as the producer holds a
gun to the baby's head
while an adult bigfoot sneaks up behind
him and
tears him in two in another the adult
big feet
towering over the producer throw him in
the cage the producer had built to keep
the baby
having been driven insane by the trauma
and screaming making sounds that quote
are almost identical to those of the
baby bigfoot
the producer is the villain and in all
of these the cinematographer and crew
only earn absolution by destroying the
film
here are some of the designs fat bigfoot
is uh your new favorite monster he's
my friend and yours um i was able to
track down one of the artists who does
not remember this at all but after
jogging some memory this there's no
explanation for what this is but it was
included alongside
the uh design so it's assumed that this
is some kind of a makeup test
um uh so one of the artists who i was
able to track down
um we just sort of uh
spitballed for a while and our best
guess
is that he would have gotten this job
through art college
and so romero would have had some
contact
at various art colleges and just put up
a flyer
soliciting designs for big feet for
a movie and um offering
you know whatever a little bit he could
pay which was probably fine
for college students in 1975.
um so this was yet another project that
never materialized at least not in that
form
but the idea never died george romero
loved bigfoot
and he loved the idea of building a
story around a camera crew in the forest
in 1994 george romero was invited to
valencia community college
a small but highly respected school in
florida
to shoot a short film as part of an
innovative uh
new endowed position this was a
remarkably fertile period for romero the
writer but an exceedingly difficult one
for romero the director as project after
project
fell through and this offered the
increasingly rare opportunity to
actually get behind a camera
the film jack rhonda joe was the first
that romero shot wholly outside of the
pittsburgh region
and the arrangement with the college was
such that none of his usual crew would
be participating
so not only has it never been screened
it's almost entirely unknown
we have a script storyboards and a bunch
of production documents
and i might have tracked down more i've
spoken to people who worked on it it was
indeed
filmed and edited and it ran about 18
minutes long
so romero conceived of the script as
proof as a proof of concept for a
feature
so although it's structured to stand on
its own it consistently gestures towards
larger arcs
the film is entirely different from
footage built around a geraldo like talk
show called
remington in which the sleazy host
interviews
a series of guests with info or opinion
on the opinions on the latest regional
news
which had brought hundreds of people to
a small town in search of a glimpse
a film crew shooting a tv show about
hunting and the outdoors
and their guest host a famous athlete
encountered a hairy ape-like
creature in the swamps near jackaronda
florida
the creature was dubbed jackaronda joe
and this
is joe um
okay so uh footage
used the device footage the 70s film uh
or
script use the device of a film crew to
discuss the ethics of filming
and to distinguish modernity's greed and
pettiness
from the more perhaps stereotypically
natural existence of the bigfoot
community
we would never actually see the footage
that was filmed by the camera operator
that was again the crux of the dramatic
conflict within the film
the footage was never found but
gleefully destroyed before it could be
developed
or viewed by anybody um uh
uh jackaronda joe takes the next step in
actually showing the footage
but with a tension-defusing device of a
sensationalist
talk show um this was romero's attempt
as he put it to see if audiences could
be scared by a documentary format
um let's see in both footage and
jacaranda joe
human-like creatures in the wilderness
offer sharp distinction
to the humans and film is essential
to that distinction in footage it
provides the potential to profit
while ensuring the destruction of a
community one whose survival is crucial
for romero
precisely because it suggests an
alternative possibility for existence
to the greed and violence of humanity
and of course
the film industry in joe that community
may have already been destroyed
because of the video crowds have flocked
to the area
rows of souvenir stands and food carts
line the main street of the closest town
and bikers rally nearby for the hell of
it
we get only the briefest of glimpses of
the creature
with no indication of the larger swamp
ape community or
family what we get instead is a
representative of the mikasuki tribe
another brief digression one of the
actors considered for the role of
benjamin the mikasugi tribal leader
was a local actor and author of choctaw
cherokee descent
who provided the producer with detailed
notes on benjamin's portrayal
that author who had not yet published
his first novel
was al going back who had quickly become
one of the most revered horror novelists
in the country
and fully separate from this project a
collaborator with romero on yet another
film for which romero
failed to gain financing so benjamin's
role is cliched to say the least
but he voices a strong critique of the
violence and indifference of white
society
he had been arrested for killing a
panther with his bare hands
as was required to join his tribal
council
and on the talk show he gets in a
shouting match with
quote redneck hunters who want to shoot
more animals
he responds more panthers are killed by
rental cars than by native americans
when they get indignant at his own
transgressions
but he goes further asking white society
to respect the laws of his community
just as the indigenous peoples have
respected theirs
benjamin's moral code requires him to
tell the truth
which as he points out white society's
geochristian
rules do as well so
in both of these uh um
sorry um so the use of diegetic
uh sorry i just got lost
my apologies okay
so um uh in in jacaranda joe
benjamin uh helps to align the critique
of uh of modern society that romero
associates with filmmaking
with a kind of more quote-unquote
stereotypically natural
existence one that's not unproblematic
obviously
um okay so this use of diegetic camera
operators to depict
filmmaking as a corrupting force however
uh goes back even further past
uh past footage past the 1970s
even beyond the start of romero's own
film career
there are of course predecessors to be
found footage horror film
that were hugely influential to romero
including peeping tom
a film in which a voyeur murders women
with a camera outfitted with a knife
and orson welles radio broadcast of war
of the worlds
powell and wells were two of romero's
favorite filmmakers
mentioned frequently in interviews as
influences and inspirations
war is actually directly referenced in
diary
and romero had clearly been thinking
about it at least since he wrote
his war of the world script in the 1980s
well powell was not only possibly
romero's biggest inspiration
but he became a friend of romero's late
in powell's life uh um
right around the time he would have been
working on jack rhonda joe
so both of those works have been
mentioned by critics and fans as clear
ancestors of the blair witch project
but there is one work that to my
knowledge never has
and it is even more crucial to romero's
artistic biography
in 1960 just after he turned 20 years
old
romero joined his friend rudy ritchie in
a small production
of jack gelber's jazz play the
connection
the sensation of new york theater in
the essential avant-garde theater troupe
the living theaters production
helped inaugurate a new era of american
drama
largely plotless the play consists of a
bunch of beatniks and junkies and jazz
musicians waiting for their heroine
dealer
romero who would later claim that he was
recruited primarily because he was large
played leech the owner of the run-down
loft in which all the junkies await
their fix
accompanied by an opportunistic writer
and two cinematographers
all of whom hope to event to ultimately
exploit
these subjects for a film one of the
subjects grows frustrated and unleashes
on the filmmakers accusing them of
treating his life
and the lives of his friends as a freak
show
so the influence of this laid-back
almost structuralist improvisatory
collaborative
uh play was uh apparent
even in something like night of the
living dead um if the connection
is about a bunch of junkies stopping
stuck in a crafty
crappy apartment until their dior's
arrives getting more and more
jumpy and tense the knight basically
transposes this basic dynamic to the
wildly fantastical dynamic
of the zombie apocalypse um
but even at that stage of even at the
earliest stage of his career
filmmaking is opportunistic and
destructive it fundamentally exploits
its subjects and asserts a dehumanizing
distance from behind the lens
romero of course did not write the
connection
in any discussions of influence however
formative they may be
are fuzzy at best but there seems to be
a direct line between the connection
and diary of the dead with a remarkable
consistency
it's even there in night of the living
dead where the news crew
led by beloved local tv host and newsman
and romero's early benefactor chili
billy bill cardill
is benign and apparently performing
essential work
but even a cuddly local hero like chilly
billy
is aligned with the all-white posse that
shoots ben right between the eyes
but of course with diary the
denunciation becomes explicit
and explicitly aligned with horror
movies as
jason's hacky mummy movie we see at the
beginning of the film
gives way to a grittier more realistic
zombie movie that destroys the lives of
everyone around him
so there's undoubtedly some dime store
psychologizing
of romero himself that we could do and
we might not be
incorrect but i want to think of this as
intentional rhetoric
one that is consistent with a filmmaking
ethos that drove him to remain
independent and remain far from the
centers of finance and production
adopting a mode of filmmaking that is
collaborative and unregimented
that remains flexible and open to change
over the course of shooting
and invites contributions from everyone
on set
what makes in diary the dead the filming
virus
so seductive and so dangerous is how
easily it becomes
exploitative and alienate alienating
how quickly it becomes an agent of
distance
if he'd been infected by the camera
virus he'd spent a lifetime
interrogating it even trying to combat
it but he was always
ambivalent about his legacy in his
career and for him
the diegetic camera and eventually the
found footage film
was an especially potent means of making
critique
so as i said before the diegetic camera
in found footage horror
tends to communicate vulnerability first
and foremost
offering a partial fragmentary view of a
scene
which monsters and other threats might
be lurking
the camera operators and diary jason in
particular
use their cameras as a way of distancing
themselves from the events in front of
them
but that distance primarily manifests in
a lack of intervention
jason cannot help or offer support to
the
to the people who are in danger or
suffering because he is hidden behind
his camera
and in the end a zombie sneaks up behind
him
and bites him as soon as he spins his
camera around
the camera is ultimately impotent
signaling both a lack of control
and a lack of protection driving away
his friends
endangering them and ultimately causing
his own death
the ending in which survivors lock
themselves away from the world to edit
the footage and film the security
monitors ironizes jason's fantasy of the
camera's gaze
they're kept safe but only by literally
locking themselves off from the rest of
the world
if this is ultimately what romero thinks
of the camera's powers and dangers
it's a critique a denunciation even in
which he
includes himself but the critique also
offers a path to a solution if
filmmaking
is isolating and inhumane then it
requires a communal collaborative
approach
one which issues the temptations of big
budget studios
and which allows for a kind of
collective expression
or at least an expression of community
to paraphrase romero from an interview
in the 1980s
the greatest tragedy of a zombie
apocalypse would not be for humanity to
be overthrown
but for the survivors to fall back into
old patterns
in society to reset as it was before
diary is his most pessimistic work
because he can't see to the other side
the camera virus has infected everyone
and even if we survive the flesh-eating
zombies
we'll be making and consuming images on
our own forever
thank you
[Music]
thank you so much whoops can you guys
hear me
i can hear you oh good hello thank you
so much adam that was really
uh really fascinating it was wonderful
to see all those archival materials
um i wonder if i i'd like to kick us off
with two questions and they're totally
different
um one is about uh diary of the dead
which um
you have so ably explained as a critique
of
of filmmaking and the notion of the
camera virus and so on
but it also is very much as you know a
sort of
uh attack on social media and
phones and blogs and the kind of it's
kind of a grumpy old man movie in
certain ways of like
100 percent you know um
and i wonder if you could talk about
that angle of the film
which of course is sort of ironic
because it's a film that mostly saw
digital distribution and people probably
watched on their phones a lot
and stuff you know because it was so
minimally distributed yeah
he was aware of that right um so that's
that's one question
and the other one is totally different
and it's um you know when you were
talking about some of the um
earlier films you know after night of
the living dead um
you kind of hopped over a creep show and
i'm wondering if you can talk a little
bit about creepshow
uh place it within his career and
and you know i'm just thinking about it
financially because you were talking
about so many of
romero's struggles and creepshow
i don't know the numbers at all but i
would be shocked if it were
a box office disaster it seems so
marketable
it's got some of the biggest stars he
had probably the biggest stars he had
before
land of the dead right i mean like hal
holbrook
first ed harris is not like big at that
point but
um you know it's got stephen king so
it's got some sort of cult appeal from
that or adrian barbeau or fritz weaver
um so i've just those two questions if
yeah
so um i'll start off with creep show so
um
after the success of dawn of the dead he
was able to parlay that into a three
picture
deal and he had financing and creative
freedom for the first
and only time in his career for those
three films with
some caveats one of them was going to be
a horror film that was a collaboration
with king
and the other one had to be another
sequel
to dawn of the dead so day of the dead
would be the third one
creep show would be the second and the
first he just had complete free reign
so he makes knight riders which is a
movie about a
modern day motorcycle jousting troop
that's modeled after
camelot and the renaissance faires it's
crazy i i like the film
quite a bit but the idea that he could
have thought of that
as commercial in any way is remarkable
um but creepshow did fine like it didn't
do
great it didn't do terrible it sort of
found
its niche audience on video over the
years
it i think it was number one at the box
office the first week that it opened
and then the studio for some reason
pulled all ads and it sank very quickly
so like again it did fine it wasn't a
disaster
day of the dead was a disaster um
it was a film that was you know dawn of
the dead
like has a lot on its mind but it's also
like
candy colored and fun and funny and day
of the dead is grim and
kind of unpleasant in a lot of ways um
and did not uh excite audiences
in the same way and the
failure of day of the dead killed a lot
of opportunities
whereas creep show like again it did
fine
but day of the dead was always going to
be the next movie
um yeah um but the other question
wait what was the other question diary
of the dad is a cranky old man movie
about oh yeah yeah oh
absolutely um and it was made in 2007 so
like the height of myspace basically
um and there's very clearly
a kind of um grumbling
towards young filmmakers uh like
especially
young filmmakers who want to be horror
guys
that you see in a lot of romero's like
uh
just very like interviews and
writings and in his films late in his
life
um i think there's for him kind of a
little bit of resist
resentment that he got saddled with
horror and there's all these people who
are like that's their only aspiration is
making a dumb zombie movie or whatever
um but he also
clearly sees okay so if it is a grumpy
old man movie
in which uh social media is
the problem um it's coming before
facebook before
iphones had been um had been introduced
and i think that what he's seeing is not
just like the kids with their phones
but everybody turning into
someone who's experienced with each
other is mediated by screens
and as he would understand that as
filmmakers as photographers and as
audiences
which is a kind of relationship that
he's very suspicious of
and that he's always sort of trying to
arrange new
[Music]
arrange new configurations for
for how the filmmaker can relate to
audiences um
and so you know i
would have liked to have had a
conversation with him um
you know in the 2010s about what he
thinks of
all these kids in his in their phones
but
yeah i mean he he tends to align
technology of any kind with a kind of
corrupting
influence with this you know kind of
stereotypical ideal of a more natural
kind of existence
that you see with big feet or you know
the proto-humans in his stanley kubrick
fan fiction
or you know again very problematically
with the mikasuki tribe in jacaranda joe
and to some extent kind of with the
zombies and like land of the dead
or survival um so
yeah i don't know he was always going to
grumble about it
great thank you who else has a question
amber thank you hi adam thank you so
much for your talk
i was wondering if you know which was
the last creep
that he wrote that couldn't produce
because i mean like you have been
telling us that
he couldn't produce a lot but i guess
like the last one
because he died or something like that
and what i was also wondering
what do you think he would be producing
right now
like with all these like social media as
heather mentioned
so it's difficult to say because at a
certain point
in the 21st century in particular
he realized that not only it like it had
gotten worse
not only was he could he only get
funding for horror
but he could only get funding for zombie
movies and more than that
only for living dead sequels
so that's a lot of what he worked on in
the last like
10 years of his life basically um
but the last script that he worked on
that i know about
um is an adaptation of a novel called
the zombie autopsies
um which was written by steve schlossman
who's like a
buddy of mine he teaches at harvard um
in the psychology department
and they were never able to get funding
for it and they
worked on this for a couple of years
going all around
you know hollywood and independent
producers and all that and just
never came to anything the last thing
so there's there's two final projects
that are are
both really interesting and they're both
written um
one is a short story called the
liberator that's a gollum
story that you can find online
it was um a collaboration with
his longtime friend george nama
who's currently married to his ex-wife
christine forrest
um but who he'd known since the 1950s
like since he first moved to pittsburgh
um and uh you know george was the one
who actually introduced him to the
owners of the monroeville mall
so that he could shoot dawn of the dead
there they'd been talking about
collaborating for a while
so george nama uh is a renowned visual
artist now
and this collaboration was for a gallery
exhibit
where nama would provide the visuals
etchings and romero would
write a story and it's in some ways very
much a grumpy old man's story
but it's really fascinating and moving
and you can you can find it online
um it's a as a it's a catalog for the
exhibit but it contains the full story
and the other thing was at a certain
point when he realized he wasn't going
to get
maybe he wasn't going to get to make a
film again but he definitely wasn't
going to get the kind of budget he
wanted
again so he started writing a novel um
that was about a quarter a third of the
way done
when he passed away and
it was an attempt to kind of summarize
but also
further the zombie
mythology and trying to tie everything
together
um it was finished by daniel krauss
after romero's death and came out a
couple of months ago it's called the
living dead
it's really great and you may find a
character
about halfway through who shows up named
heart
um that's not a coincidence
it's the coolest thing that's ever
happened to me
which is that in the george romero uh
zombie novel uh my buddy dan wrote me in
as a character
so um yeah
but other than that i don't know what he
would be working on because you see
just like a drop-off in production at a
certain point when he's sort of like
he's old but also like
he just like he had had in the 90s and
early 2000s
so many projects fell through and
like that happens to any filmmaker but
when you're working like as
independently as he did like
everything has to go right for a film to
get made
so like one project got cancelled
because
it was too similar to this new keanu
reason sandra bullock movie called speed
that was gonna beat them to theaters
there was another one where
somehow it all hinged on getting a star
like sharon stone to be in it and then
he somehow got the money to offer her 12
million dollars or something like that
and she turned it down because she
didn't want to be in a [__] ghost
movie
he he does that kind of impression when
he tells the story
um and there's just like lots of little
things like that
and it just happened so many times that
you know like at a certain point and at
a certain point in your life like when
you're in your 60s i think you
stop writing a script every day
and stop like having that ambition to
make your
science fiction epic that uh adapts
tales of hoffman into a space rock
musical
um you know and so
it's mostly zombie stuff in the 21st
century
and not much
else besides the projects that got made
um after like 2005 or six
yeah thank you
who's next i can't see everyone's hand
but i see laura
hi adam thank you so much for uh your
presentation i found it fascinating
i have to admit that my question is
coming uh directly
from what you presented and
um because i myself am have not watched
these films i
uh don't do well with horror although i
very much appreciate horror
i'm trying to get better at that so uh
i'll make it a point to watch some of
these soon
my question is kind of thinking about
like two questions but one is thinking
about
um how you you talked about that there
was increasing isolation or he
represents increasing isolation due to
the over mediatization or
um us seeing each other through screens
only
i'm wondering if there was also uh
influence
particularly of kind of neoliberal
policies that were
coming out in you know the 80s 90s that
were affecting the pittsburgh community
if that had any effect on on his work as
well it's
it's just hard for me to um you know
when i hear things about
isolation or even when you're talking
about um what seems to be ethics of care
with
bigfoot and and caring for the family
it's really hard for me to to think that
that may not have had
some sort of influence on him and
i'll quick see the second one just so
anyone else can get in uh the second one
has to do with i was really interested
when he talked about
um the the use of a black character in
his first film
um uh and and that that wasn't
necessarily a choice and how interesting
that is
but that it seemed like he almost leaned
into um kind of a racial narrative
in terms of it's hard to ignore the it
looking like a racial lynching the way
that the final film came out
so i'm wondering about the effects of
that um if you could just talk about
those two things please
yeah absolutely so um
in in terms of uh like the the
politics of the 90s and 2000s um
it it drove him out of pittsburgh
basically
um you know the the tax code and various
other you know right-wing or neo-liberal
sort of changes within the state made it
almost impossible
for him to film here and so it doesn't
seem like a coincidence to me that all
of his stuff in the 21st century
um you know four films that he shot in
toronto or at least in canada um
they all feel very they're very much
about isolation and seclusion
um it's not that that's not there before
but it seems to have like a different
sort of
manifestation in those movies um
because like the community in pittsburgh
and the city
and the sort of family of filmmakers
that he had
developed were all always incredibly
important to him
you know you see you read interviews
with him from
just after night of the living dead or
actually even before that
and he's as interested in building a
film industry in pittsburgh
as he is in making the next movie now of
course he's you know
obviously interested in making the next
movie also but
you know he he doesn't leave for
hollywood which
you know if you don't make any money off
of night of the living dead the way you
cash in on it
is to use it as your calling card at all
the studios and then
get that gets you in the door but that
never even occurred to him instead he
wanted to build hollywood
on the mon which is not a very catchy
tagline
but which i see repeated a few times in
the early 1970s
and so you know when he has to like it
it very literally drives him away
and at a time after which like in the
early 1990s like he seemed to have
succeeded there were a bunch of
high-profile
film productions that he did not make
that was that were in pittsburgh and so
like
his friends his colleagues
you know a whole new generation of
filmmakers
got to stay in the city and got to keep
working and you know
um there wasn't really a film school
here at the time and so
you know there's a whole generation
of uh film crew and producers and such
who basically learned how to make a
movie
on the set of silence of the lambs
or night of the living dead or you know
this
really strange john landis movie called
innocent blood
or some of george's like late 80s early
90s productions
and then over the course of the 90s it
basically makes it impossible for him to
stay
um i do think that he
thought about things in a sort of he he
did have a political perspective on
on the world but that
the way that it would have manifested
most viscerally for him was
in that literal exile from the community
that meant so much to him
and god i did it again i forgot what the
second question was
uh in the night of the living dead oh
yeah yeah
thank you thank you very much for the
first answer as well thank you
um so uh you know he always
he always claims that it was completely
unintentional
that dwayne jones the actor was just the
best actor who showed up
um but that's [__] like yes they did
not write a script
intending it to be you know um intending
it to be like a civil rights
um you know didactic tract or whatever
but you don't have a script in which a
black man
uh slaps a white woman and shoots a
white man
and then have you know like a white
posse with german shepherds
kill him you don't do that unless you
know that what the
political residence is like these are
choices
that you know you would have to be not
just naive but stupid to not
understand like had some kind of meaning
um
and you know it
i think that at some level he recognized
that that gave the film a kind of
thematic ambition that a lot of um
that a lot of horror films didn't have
although it's not uncommon for a science
fiction film and
george was a huge fan of like 50s
science fiction
um you know in later years he and other
like
um horror fans were kind of denounced
there's a
corny science fiction explanation about
radiation from
the moon or something that may have
caused the dead to rise
it's like i don't know we shouldn't no
no explanation no explanation that that
makes it cheesy and corny
but that's what he was into he liked
cheesy science fiction movies
and it's not unusual for science fiction
movies to have that sort of political
commentary particularly about racism and
intolerance like that's something you
see in
you know uh 50s and 60s science fiction
over and over again
um and so like i think at some
level he recognized that he could use
this movie for that
um i think like he's sort of a
you know like more sort of like middle
of the road liberal in the sense that
he's much more concerned with like
um acknowledging the um
like the the value of one's humanity
rather than exploring the you know like
specific oppressions of being a
black man in america in 1968
um or you know like the the specifics of
what misogyny or homophobia means at
the time that he's making a film but
that doesn't mean that they're they're
completely absent like he's
you know has this kind of vague sort of
uh
humanist approach to politics
uh vaguely humanist i you know whatever
anyways um but he thinks that it's
important any and
he's really driven by this sense of like
society needing to
change um even in his more optimistic
movies like
his he's his more optimistic movies are
mostly optimistic about
like being able to tear down the whole
system and
start something else you know
knight riders which again bizarre movie
bizarre choice to make like i got free
reign
i'm gonna make the motorcycle jouster
movie like that's
what crazy um but it's all about
like a community that sort of forms on
the outside of society with its
own rules that's all about like honoring
each other
and following a different code than
everybody else follows
and so in a lot of ways like knight
rider feels like this
key to his entire filmography
you know of him wanting to build a
different kind of
society basically um
yeah long-winded answer
but yeah
um thank you so much for your your talk
um i wanted to follow up on what you
were just saying and also
um i i mean just
it seems like um there's a theme
throughout much of what you're
talking about um in which
you know it makes me think that um the
kind of um critique
of the act of filming
critique of the camera as as sort of
dehumanizing
um that
on on a more specific level could
could that be seen as a critique of
hollywood
itself you know from someone who was an
outsider not just by choice but also by
these constant rejections right um
of his scripts and and so um
even the idea that you just mentioned of
creating an outsider society
um you know echoes with what you were
saying earlier about
the kind of outsider community of
filmmakers that he
fostered in in pittsburgh so i'm curious
to hear about
um you know either specifically in the
archive in his own
writings or interviews or letters you
know what
what you found of him talking about
hollywood as an industry
he absolutely hated it um you know he
i think he's one of those people who
never sold out because he was
physically incapable of doing so um
you know he got a couple of
opportunities as a teenager to
be like a pa uh
some hollywood productions including one
i think north by northwest
um and it really sort of soured him on
the way that hollywood works um
you know he liked hitchcock but he was
never like a
he he was never somebody who he brought
up in
uh you know like in interviews as an
inspiration or something like that and i
think it's because of that experience
where everything seemed so rigid and
hitchcock was always sort of in battle
with
the studio having to find ways to work
around them and that largely came
through
like very inflexible planning
for everything um
but what he really disliked about
hollywood
was the sense of
the sense of exploitation at the expense
of the filmmakers
this sense that like the people who are
making the film
don't get to decide what the film should
be
and in his you know his fortations with
hollywood with a film called monkey
shines that's
you know it's good but flawed let's say
um he was forced to
film a like an absurd happy ending
um that you know takes place in the
well in the building that i'm in right
now it takes place right outside of it
so like i kind of appreciate that about
it but
i you know he's it's it is absurd um
and his experience filming the dark half
uh stephen king adaptation
with um you know like what they used to
call a mini major
uh studio was the worst experience of
his life
his wife at the time believes he had a
stroke in the middle of it just
from stress and
you know when all that money gets
involved
and all of those you know intermediaries
then it becomes the decisions are not
made
based on what makes the film better
or worse in the kind of free-flowing
way that he liked to work and that he
thought was a lot of fun
sort of disappears and so in the 90s you
know
i said he couldn't get a film made um
but he was
able to get a bunch of scripts
sold and i think he just sort of like
had a sort of working retirement like he
was
around 60 at that time and he loved
writing
he managed to make it into a sort of
collaborative
effort where he would work with his
producer but he'd also bring in you know
novelists and filmmakers and all sorts
of people
and they'd you know like uh they'd
drink and smoke and come up with
a new script uh and if he was all alone
he'd just like wake up in the morning
and put on espn
or old movies and start typing away at
his typewriter
um and so in a lot of ways like that
sort of becomes
his vocation more than actual
filming of movies um
but you know there was a lot of
resentment that
was uh obviously tinged with bitterness
um you know at a certain point he did
like he would have
liked to have sold out to make war of
the worlds or
his adaptation of the stand or you know
like he
did have like big ideas but hollywood
basically
considered him an immature even though
dawn of the dead and night of the dead
had been
you know big hits because he had never
worked in the studios before
so i think that only sort of cemented
his
resentment of hollywood um
yeah in that context could you talk
briefly about
land of the dead as a studio picture i
i saw him um at a screening of diary of
the dead
and um he wasn't
completely negative about land of the
dead but he had not enjoyed the
production experience at all and he
expressed quite a bit of relief
you know to do the diary of the dead
after that and
you know just enjoying no longer being
beholden to the suits who were bossing
around and so on
um i mean and at the time i thought yes
but land of the dead is like
really solid and in many ways a better
film than diary the dead
yeah but that's not how he saw it
i think um so i've talked to a couple of
people who worked on land of the dead
and it was
it was kind of a horrifying experience
for
george because it was so intense it just
required so much of him
um in the sense that he was
you know like he was not just making the
film but
like answering to all of these suits and
managing the sort of logistics for
what was probably his biggest production
at that point um and
you know i i think he's
very bad at the logistics he's a
terrible businessman
he's terrible at organization like his
ideal
um is kind of night of the living debt
like he always was sort of like
trying to chase that dragon of night of
the living dead but
with money enough to print out a new
draft of the script
when they made some changes or so that
everyone didn't have to sleep on
the floor of the house they're they're
filming in
um but land of the dead was the film on
which like
it had been so long since he had had a
hit
like his entire career his ability to
ever make a film again was writing on it
he had made one film in the previous
decade
and it was bruiser a film which i'm
guessing nobody
here has seen because almost nobody has
seen it
um and cert okay
i should have known um but not very many
people
like it it was a
um it was a pretty notorious
flop um and the only way
you know as with dawn of the dead making
another sequel was the only way he could
get back into feature filmmaking
um so so much was writing on it that he
just like was putting in 20-hour
days he was like he would have been
in his 60s at that point um so
he uh you know was exhausted
um and like i don't think he could
physically have ever done that again
um i do think that his opinions
of his movies are largely based on
his experience filming them yeah so he
loves knight riders because it was the
most fun movie
like he hung out with his friends in the
country and you know like he and ed
harris got really close and they
rode some motorcycles and uh made
tom savini pose in a speedo and you know
like just had a bunch of
uh had a bunch of picnics and such you
see the behind the scenes
pictures and it's like one big party um
but uh you know like
land of the dead i think is one that
he likes the movie fine but he does not
look back on it with particular fondness
for that
reason i think i would put in um a quick
plug for land of the dead because i know
some of us
here don't want i think laura identified
herself as not watching all the horror
films and and maybe some of you haven't
seen
uh many or any romero movies
and land of the dead is a real standout
for me
um as a not a post 911 movie and it's a
film
critical of george w bush
and maybe the first theatrical
feature american theatrical feature to
really kind of
take that on in a serious way through
the allegory of
science fiction horror so i think it
might be a good starter film for some
people who maybe
don't come to it as zombie lovers or
aficionados but
would be is it in that political context
yeah
it was i mean it was the most political
theatrical release
of was that
of whichever year it was released like
just after the iraq war started and it
was like you know there was no other
theatrical film that was that
explicitly political yeah the only other
thing i can think of around that time
it would be the masters of horror
episode homecoming which is not
theatrical film but like
if another zombie movie right so laura
just said like that could get me into
horror i would also recommend the
masters of horror showtime series
episode called the homecoming that is a
zombie episode that is
very harsh about george w bush yeah for
some reason
the like uh elder statesman of horror
got together and decided that zombie
movies in 2005 or 2006
zombie movies were the uh the proper
vehicle for
denouncing the iraq war um
in in land of the dead um dennis hopper
is doing a donald rumsfeld impression
um and you know like the it's it's his
most
explicitly political film with like a
capital p
like it's about politics um
you know i i think that um subtlety is
uh
overrated as a um uh
as an aspect of cinema yeah home and
homecoming which is not romero to be
clear it's um
uh is it joe dante it's joe dante yeah
yeah um
but uh homecoming like features voting
prominently like
zombie voting yeah i want to say more
than that but
what at a moment we're thinking about
voting a lot it's particularly um it's
good
um and i'll just i'll just say like so
um
you know this this talk was cut down
considerably from a first draft that
could have lasted three hours um
uh but one of the things that i talked
about in there
was um you know it's not just that
romero kind of stumbled backwards into
horror after he couldn't get
other stuff made um but
he kind of only made one movie that ever
tried to scare people
like night of the living dead was a very
scary movie for 1968 i don't know if
it'll give you nightmares
in 2020 um not just because you know
reality is scary enough but um
you know after that he would use horror
um
as a way to you know tell different
kinds of stories
uh whether it's a zombie movie or a
vampire movie
or you know creep show which is like an
adaptation of 50s or a
transposition of 50s
you know cheesy horror comics like
they're all thought of as horror and
i guess they are but it's not horror in
the sense they're trying to
like scare you or give you nightmares
they're using
monsters and horror tropes to do
whatever he was interested in basically
um it's 6 35 we could take another
maybe one last question if there's
anyone i cannot see your hand so hop in
if you um anyone okay i think there's an
a question in the q a oh
uh sorry um
let's see uh tim jackson what was his
history with brother blue i always
thought it was wonderful for the
storyteller's legacy that he was in
knight riders
yeah um i don't have a ton of insights
into that
um he was george was pretty terrible at
keeping
records and most of the production
documents that we have
are from the 80s 90s and 2000s when
somebody else was keeping records
so we don't have a ton but what i do
know about brother blue is that
he was somebody that george knew from
pittsburgh
like he just he knew him from like
working in
or you know like traveling in the same
circles he was
local color not unlike you know heather
and i are both huge fans of a
documentary called sweet sal
um that's about just like a local
guy in braddock who's you know strange
and delightful and just completely
charismatic and charming
and george just put him in his movie uh
in
in night writers um and you know
he had written the part of
um merlin for
a like a black man
um supposedly morgan freeman read for
the part
but he only read for the part this is
the way george would tell the story
so that he could lecture george
afterwards and say
this part should be a part for a man not
a black man
george said well it says in the script
black man and that's the character
and so it's a strange little anecdote
um but i think he always had brother
blue in mind
for it like whether or not he could have
hired morgan freeman that would
certainly
put the it would put the film into
it would make it something else for sure
but
he is he's kind of him himself
like he's given a character and
uh you know lions and all of that but
he's asked to bring that sort of local
color
um in a way that romero often
likes to do in his movies especially at
that time
when he was you know really sort of
tapped into pittsburgh i guess
great well thank you um and thank you
amber for pointing out that i missed
that
one in the q a um i think maybe we're
ready to
wrap up um thank you so much adam for
your time and presenting all this really
uh
interesting material and um i encourage
anyone who has more
questions or thoughts or follow-up to
get in touch with adam directly
um and i'm sure there's so much more to
share
so thank you if we could pause
yay um thanks heather thanks thanks
scott thanks everybody
um this was a lot of fun and um
yeah no i put my uh email address
in the chat and you know if anybody has
any follow-ups please
feel free i obviously love talking about
this stuff so
don't don't hold back that's great
thanks so much all right i'm going to uh
end
this meeting now then bye everybody
thank you all
right thank you